Let's go next to our caller from the nine,
seven, eight area code.
Who's calling today from 978?
I am very Fitzgibbons.
I'm sorry, did you say your name's Brett?
Right.
Yes.
What's going on, Bre?
Well, let me tell you something.
I've I've put in my application to the city
hall for a mail in ballot.
Yeah, well, it was never delivered the by
the post office.
OK, let's back up, Brett.
Where?
So where what part of the country are you
talking about?
You're here in Boston.
On the North Shore.
North Shore.
Okay.
And did you call and ask what's going on with
your ballot?
Yeah, I did.
And that's they always e-mailed them out a
week ago and it was never delivered.
Yeah.
So I actually it took me three weeks to get
mine.
And I when I called, they said and this is
a quote, it's because of what's going on with
the post office, which struck me as very ominous.
So, I mean, I do think, you know, you're talking
about for the September first primary, right?
Yeah.
Which is just now just days away.
I was asking for the mail in ballot for the
presidential.
But they don't rule it.
Wait, wait a second, hold on, let me back
up.
Right.
Are you.
Are you saying you you're waiting on the ballot
for November?
Yes.
Oh, no, they haven't sent those out yet.
There hasn't.
There's still a primary on September 1st.
It's fired.
You shouldn't have gotten the November ballot
yet.
That's normal.
Nobody's gotten it yet.
In Massachusetts.
I've got no doubt.
Now to me.
Did you request the Democratic primary ballot
because you do have to request that.
Yes, I did.
Yes, you did.
OK.
So that's the one I'd be concerned about,
the November one?
Not so much.
It's yeah, it's a problem.
Now, if you don't get it by September 1st,
will you go in and vote in person?
We get what we get early voting right now.
Oh, OK.
I have to get out to vote this week.
You're going to do it.
OK, very good.
Will you?
I mean, listen, it's a mess.
I'm hearing these stories from all over the
country.
Yes, to crime.
Yes.
All right, my friend, Brett, thank you for
the call.
Great to hear from you.
And yet another data point about how bad it
is with a lot of this post office shenanigans
that are going on.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding.
Don't hang up because I'm going right back
to the phones momentarily.